you know it's really hard when you make
a career as a winner as a as in the
image of luxury and success to confront
the fact that you failed and it's also
really hard to claim Underdog status
when you've been president of the United
States that only kind of works so long
and on top of that Trump's style his
sort of bombastic
aggressive uh style which works for him
because he's been doing that on
television in the press for 30 years or
more uh when other people try to copy it
his surrogates and those around him it
continues to fall flat and it seems
inauthentic so it doesn't have the vibe
so to speak and so in some ways by
trying to copy Trump as CPAC has and
failing to capture the authenticity you
kind of fail to capture what is
interesting about Trump which is a more
Transcendent appeal